ce qui est bien c'est qu'en fait on est
tous potes et c'était beaucoup plus
facile de travailler ensemble beaucoup
plus facile la complicité qu'on avait
déjà entre nous trois parce que c'est
important d'avoir les danseurs plus de
chorégraphes qui s'entendent bien et
comme ça si eux ils ont des suggestions
dont je prends tout le temps ça se
passait à merveille
on écoute seul tome pour iam je me suis
dit 'c'est l'acrobate il faut qu'on
passe des trucs impressionnants
j'ai vu faire des défis pas des salles
peu en arrière des supers yeux vous
allez voir une petite brise c'est assez
flippant et et lui il fallait juste que
je la fasse un peu plus bouger on la
rend très sexy fait déjà que 200 marche
super bien on dirait que c'est des
meilleurs amis qui se connaissent depuis
des années des années
alors du coup la complicité qu'on
voulait créer dans cette forêt c'était
en jean de l'amitié qu'ils ont on sent
qu'il ya une petite attraction le fait
de s'entendre aussi bien je pense que ça
aide que la danse soit encore plus
fluide et plus belle
[Musique]